a sunday service with special poignancy
the first of the war
prayers here for peace extinguished just
days ago
as if in answer russian and ukrainian
delegations are meeting on the border
with belarus
it is the first glimmer of negotiation
but few including ukraine's president
expect a positive outcome
i'll say frankly i don't believe in the
result of this meeting but let's try so
that no citizen of ukraine would doubt
that i as president did try to stop the
war when there was even just a small
chance
the russian attack has renewed its focus
on critical infrastructure
a gas pipeline ablaze in the eastern
city of kharkiv ukraine's second largest
[Music]
russian soldiers trying to enter kharkiv
on sunday met determined ukrainian
resistance western intelligence claims
the russian advance is being frustrated
on all fronts
russian sources tell a different story
here defense ministry pictures claim to
show their forces making progress in the
south between the towns of hassan and
berdyansk near crimea
a missile strike did this to the
vasilkev air base setting an oil depot
ablaze part of ongoing efforts to knock
out ukraine's air defenses and gain
control of the skies vasilkev is 40
kilometers from the capital kiev
you have seen that during the whole day
there were attacks from ballistic
missiles including to our airport which
we have contained and now they are
continuing shelling but all will be good
the night will not be easy not here
neither in kiev but we will withstand
[Music]
and it is the capital that remains the
russians principal goal
frequent air raid sirens keep nerves on
edge
if they're not in bomb shelters or
subway stations most civilians are
housebound a city-wide curfew is in
place until monday and anyone out and
about is treated with extreme suspicion
in towns and cities across ukraine civil
defense units continue to form and arm
themselves russia's army may be much
larger than ukraine's but its soldiers
are well outnumbered by ordinary
ukrainians willing to stand and fight
i'm going to war i'm going to war my
brother will stay with my mother and my
grandmother and i'll go to war with my
father
at the station in the western city of
lev women children foreign nationals and
international students all trying to
leave
the rail network still operating built
for public convenience and now a
lifeline for all
this is the rabbit
his name is pasha
and
these birds we call lima and
[Music]
mara is a medical student trying to get
home to nigeria
it's been very
very emotional very
stressful
you didn't expect your time in ukraine
would end like this
i did it now
no i was i was a bit hopeful but
like everything would be okay like it
wouldn't get to this level but
the trains don't leave regularly three
to five a day perhaps there is no
timetable for the evacuation of people
who just days ago could not have
imagined that war would turn their lives
upside down like this and now as
refugees they join what could yet become
a human exodus of historic proportions
the un's refugee agency says close to
400 000 people have left for neighboring
countries so far it warns that number
could rise to 4 million jonah al jazeera
love